hey how's it going bros my name is
pierpa welcome to the evil within
we are really getting spoiled with
horror games it is october
after all but still uh
alien isolation evil within we got to
play the teaseable
teaser for salan hills i'm so excited
for this game i got to check it out a
little bit
casual or survival let's go to survival
uh
so i kind of have an idea what's about
to happen
but it's just a really cool game from
what i can tell so far like
it's supposed to be 20 hours
oh my god
well perfect atmosphere that was a
thunder outside our house
shut up again oh my god that was so
loud i don't know if he picked up
jesus that must have been just outside
that [ __ ] thing came up head guy
that's some entertainment for the
loading screen
well let's see if this game is as scary
as the lightning going on outside
i really hope your brothers will stick
through through me through this series
i always love sharing this type of stuff
with you and especially games that i
feel really passionate about so edgar
you seriously need to shut up
this is not okay
everyone there is overweight and
unhealthy i know you're just coming off
a case but i'm afraid we're gonna have
to make a detour
sounds serious is it a riot a call went
out just before i picked you up
said it was multiple homicides half a
dozen units already on scene
one three one please advocate he beats
the ghost of that doctor who went schizo
and chopped up all those patients
that's not what happened some patients
disappeared
some kind of scandal still gives you the
creeps doesn't it
please respond joseph can you spot the
main character
that's a possibility i believe the
record nice gloves man
skinky dispatch this is detective
castiano's in 184 what's the situation
over he's supposed to be spanish
[Applause]
[Music]
seriously
what is this bacon hospital all about is
that a circus
i'm scared
[Music]
get ahold of me shut up
nothing yet i'm sure we'll know
everything once we get there
they have houses like that in the middle
of the oh
oh oh
are we the backup i don't want to be the
backup
no he's chasing his own pants what do
you make of it
contact dispatch and let them know
what's happening joseph kidman
you're with me we're gonna have a look
around right
hey it's like what the [ __ ] all right
so we're we're i feel very confident
about this not going terribly i like my
trench coat
is that how you say it look at this
house
what the [ __ ] in the middle of the city
in the middle of the city let's check it
out
i bet nothing evil is inside there
within sorry
got it all wrong
um well
am i just supposed to go inside all
alone am i the only one who's main
enough
carlos i love all spanish people are
just automatically badass
smells like blood what all right stay
sharp
how can you smell blood is he a vampire
he must be check it out don't let anyone
else through this door
i can be an extra set of eyes we don't
know what's happening here
you're a backup
really well we're [ __ ] then
she even closed the door he's serious
um this is the moment where i pull out a
gun
if i have one did you hear anything
i don't know jesus who would walk into
this
he's cray-cray what
oh that's cute he just wanted to hugs
he seems pretty alive too what the hell
happened here
who's alive
who are you injured
what happened here can't be real
impossible rubik is alive
the security cameras might tell us
something
jesus thunderman it's perfect
couldn't have ordered anything better
let's check the security cameras
very slowly all right so there was a man
uh three men shooting their pistols
and then carlos would be like what is
that what are they
see itself what the hell
uh oh
uh oh i met him before
i met him in the death
what
what just happened
what the ah
gotta love this classical music oh he
got me
hello mr rat tell the king please
oh oh
this can't be good bros i'm just just a
wild guess
oh
oh [ __ ] does that guy have a
[ __ ] knife oh maybe we can reach it
okay i can rotate the camera but maybe i
can dangle
oh god what goes what is he doing
what what the [ __ ]
why is he upside down oh wait i'm upside
down
grab the knife
can i jingle oh god he's he's oh god all
right we're dead
this has been great bros
i have to shake haters gonna hey hey hey
hey hey
oh there we go now i can do it i have to
wait for him to go away okay
i'm just gonna shake shake shake shake
shake i knew i had taylor swift in me
that sounded wrong don't quote me on
that please what
come on just gotta [ __ ]
no come on you're teasing me
there we go thank you gary
that is you ow i didn't think that
through did i
i never think anyone think through bros
i like my outfit it looks like a swedish
folk dance outfit
very nice white swag i like it all right
now listen carefully blows we have to
approach him very
very cautiously yes
oh no no no no he has a great beard
is it ken where's he going
where the fudge cake is he going well
i gotta give him props for his
impeccable music taste
and wall art it's quite nice not a lot
of people
appreciate a bag of meat like i do
thank you ordinary keys i'll take oh
nice the guts are hanging out
oh hello um uh
i'm just gonna shake shake nope i'm
gonna lose my arm sorry i always mix
those up
holy [ __ ] did not expect that
not gonna lie what the [ __ ]
gotcha just like catching pokemon
except not at all the same
but he will never know nice bloody wall
i have to appreciate a nice bloody wall
some people don't uh oh oh nice
nice i probably came through there
that's nice i probably smell very nice
too
here we go we did it
[Music]
okay that means we lost them
easy now at this point i would literally
just sprint the [ __ ] up with the stairs
but i don't think we should do that
let's take it easy the graphics in these
games are amazing
a fire extinguisher can we use you come
on
well i can appreciate me
oh [ __ ] smurf go go go go go go go go
come on man you can do it
don't look back [ __ ] don't i'm serious
don't look back
what whoa did he get me
uh oh what is that
oh we made it oh we did not make
it what a lovely collection of blades
you have here
go don't go so oh [ __ ]
oh how convenient
oh nice where i love slides
oh god are you [ __ ] kidding me
oh my god this oh it's [ __ ]
oh my i got
so much gore so much gore
oh jesus i love blood pudding
but this is just too much thank god
there's a ladder
this is amazing so far [ __ ] love it
how did we get here guess it's not
important
we watched him we saw him i can't walk
here okay there we go
he's really struggling or he's really
trying to rave it out
this is how i dance when it's around my
pants ah there we go
i know there's yeah he's like [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah i showed those [ __ ] whose
boss
that's right what you gonna do about it
ah okay don't kill me
don't let the meat meet guy see there's
lights
that means there's hope don't be scared
bros it's just a game
don't be scared don't be scared like i
am never scared ever in my life
i'm i'm seriously worried about the
thunder striking down or some [ __ ] like
that
i can still faintly hear it all right
should we go here or
there wow sure you lie we did that
okay well i suppose
okay i played enough horror games
where's the exit don't talk to me when
i'm talking to the bros please
i played enough horror games to know
that guy is going to jump up on me all
right
i know your tricks i know your
little things old note from sewer
besides the lock gate at the far end of
the server there's a ladder which you
can take to the old war
okay so it's the ladder there if you
could make it through there
uh an elevator which will let you
outside okay
sounds cool ah it didn't scare me
well never mind then i guess i don't
know [ __ ]
yeah that door will work like
he didn't even try the other door but
that door he'll try
he's an optimist there you are ladder
will you lead me to the elevator please
anything can happen anything can happen
[Music]
come on gonzalez you can do it
don't climb so [ __ ] slow i ain't got
all day
jeez all right what do we got here let's
click this button see what it does
oh that went better than expected
hi gasoline just raving it out don't
worry about me
this will be the new fad this will be
the new twerking
all the cool kids will do it now where's
that elevator
seriously though i want to get out
please please can i get out
so many doors oh so so many doors
i can hide
oh god
he's coming great all right well i'll
better hide then
oh oh [ __ ] he's paced
jesus oh
what the [ __ ] checkpoint
okay what just happened
where'd he go where did i go
where did i go oh oh oh
oh my bad
wrong door oh god let him see me
okay oh [ __ ]
nice pants are those prada
hey look [ __ ] i hope you didn't hear me
uh-oh uh-oh
is he gonna come here how do i know
jesus calm down man
okay we got this thing in a bag bruce
i don't know what thing we have in a bag
but whatever we have in a bag
it's in the bag and i don't know if
that's a good thing
but it is a thing and things are good
to think okay a bottle
oh we can use that to distract him
excellent hopefully he won't kill us now
oh god oh god oh god he's so angry he's
so angry
oh god oh god run run run
ah freedom freedom freedom freedom
please
freedom please i'll take it thank you
thank you very much
i'm just gonna shake shake shake [ __ ]
please
no wheelchair oh god why am i so bad at
this
i'm just gonna shake shake shake shake
three haters gonna hey there's the
elevator
come on bros oh god oh that's
actually pretty convenient thank you go
gonzalez
all the way across the sky
ha easy peasy
lemon gonzalez
what was that
what was that oh here we go
oh intro time
funky sing it to me bruh
you're not singing
well try something
[Music]
nice nice imagery hello
is gonna be an epic adventure bros i'm
so excited to be playing this and
sharing this with you bros
it's gonna be amazing zayn from one
direction told me that
he literally just texted me yes we text
each other all the time
all the time oh new floor
new possibilities and ways to die
there we go i already died once in this
game
and it wasn't pretty i'll tell you that
oh god the door
nailed it wait we're back here what the
fudge cake
i know where the exit is over here i'll
go with exodus please
let me guess oh what
oh oh
well that's i don't i don't think that's
a good thing
good thing the ambulance is here
okay
oh [ __ ]
i think i'm his senpai it's kind of cute
actually
look at that hair who wouldn't want
invested senpai
oh my located
where the [ __ ] are all these poor dying
person
where's joseph man i'm sorry but you
never came out
i waited but
please settle down leslie
who's leslie and what has leslie got to
do with this
[ __ ] there's no going back
oh okay
oh jesus
poor leslie
that crane is dancing
love it
can mor where are all the people can
everything be a little more [ __ ]
please
this is just insane
gonzalez doesn't even break a sweat
let's go what's that what's this
what is [ __ ] what
oh that's awesome
what what is happening best
it's pretty awesome or
depends if you like destruction or not i
guess
so we made it out of the city
damn it how are we cut off from everyone
everyone must be dead
oh well aren't you an optimist everyone
all right back there
just a few bumps we're fine fine
fine we will be once we're far away fine
a little i remember him
uh oh fine fine
fine fine fine fine
fall what
white oh
this is this game is a trip man
what is not happening in this game
chapter one
clear high five bros i didn't even do
anything
love it i'll have to end the first part
there if you
enjoyed all right if this video gets 70
000 likes
like i did with alien uh there was an
embargo things i couldn't upload it
right away but this one definitely
seventy thousand likes all of the part
two right away for you bryce
it's not a deal i think that's a deal
all right thanks for being awesome stay
awesome bros